I was 21 years old I just moved to New
York from Boston to pursue stand-up
comedy and I was totally broke and the
first job I got was at this doggy
daycare service where I drove dogs
around in the van I would have to like
pull up in double Park and block
whatever busy in the cat meowed I was on
and everybody's like honking profusely
then I run into an apartment the owners
not there so I have to convince this
Rottweiler who was trying to murder me
that I wasn't burglar and I was there to
pick them up to break them to doggy
daycare and then the dog would jump in
the back of the van and start fighting
the other dogs and then three dogs would
run out into traffic and like just waves
of feces and urine like slapping me in
the face and I'm like super allergic to
dogs too something great aggravation for
me so I'm like constantly sick and in a
tornado
[ __ ] piss I finally made it back to
biscuits and bath doggy daycare and I
bring the dogs all back inside I was so
proud that I had all the dogs and they
were like we're alive and I was alive
and they were like you're ten minutes
late
what's wrong with you and I was like
cool cool cool I have a bachelor's
degree she's like that's meaningless so
you should go I got fired it was a 24
hour I had a job for 24 hours yeah so
double [ __ ] biscuits and baths seeing
dog hell
shirt